[Applause]
okay so when when i used to live in new
york i lived there in the 90s when
giuliani was mayor
and there was a saying giuliani time
yeah you remember that
you never heard that amado diallo right
yeah well
i mean you know he was a tough on-crime
mayor
and the cops loved him and when they
would do some bad to somebody
before they started it was like it's
giuliani time
you don't remember that i've never lived
in new york they
giuliani time came to giuliani's
apartment
this week the fbi this this is
i just want people to understand how
unprecedented this is for a former
just a lawyer let alone a former
prosecutor
mayor of new york the president's
personal lawyer
and the f i mean this is the scary
i mean it was 6 a.m
he was just getting in his coffin
for them to you know this is the no alar
you know just
can you this is when you your pants
literally i mean you know
and took his phones and they're
investigating now
you know rudy would say they hate me for
being loyal yes loyal to the
horrible president and a scummy guy so i
can't feel too sorry for about him
but unprecedented yes now is this
unprecedented
for one of two reasons is it political
payback is this politics
or is it because what giuliani and trump
did
was unprecedented i would say that right
too uh what are you i don't know how
unprecedented this is you i mean come on
the
administration the nixon administration
there's a lot of those guys went to jail
but did they
but did they involve themselves with
other countries i feel like
one we they did no i'm just i'm
following your train of thought i feel
like yes we play dirty politics yeah but
we used to always just have one rule
no ringers keep it in the family
do what you do you know but don't bring
in
the guy from russia yeah you know this
i don't this seemed like now look a lot
of the stuff we found out
we're finding out was reported
erroneously you mean russiagate yes
some there are things about that but the
basic idea
see my theory is that we forget that
trump was
both an idiot and crazy
really i i feel like this is very
important
like like an idiot is i
i didn't know healthcare was complicated
no one that's an idiot
or like i can charm kim jong that's an
idiot
crazy is like doing your crimes in
public
which he did and that doesn't compute so
we like thought it had to be more of a
conspiracy
it may turn out that most of it really
was just what he did in public
because it's so insane that he was
russia if you're listening
and when he admitted he fired comey
we i when i look back i'm like wow we
lived through this
you